this week on the dish we're taking you
to london to hear the extraordinary
story of chef ahmad al-arnab who serves
an array of delicately flavored dishes
at his restaurant ahmad syrian kitchen
which by the way won the best
breakthrough award at gq's food awards
in april but el arnab's journey to the
top of london's food scene is this
incredible as his food mts taeyapp went
to meet him
at imad syrian kitchen
in the heart of london's
hyper-competitive soho district
diners dive into dishes bursting with
flavors of the middle east
leading the kitchen is the restaurant's
owner and head chef imad al-arnab who
traces his love of food to the streets
of the syrian capital damascus where he
used to run a chain of restaurants cafes
and juice bars
but the arab spring uprisings would soon
change everything
how did your life change
in 2012
when syria's uprising turned into a
civil war for some moments i didn't have
a life at all i didn't have a moment to
think about
losing my restaurants you have something
much more important to take care of
which is
your family
by 2015 the brutality of the war left
him with little choice but to leave the
only home he'd ever known and so with
the few dollars and the english he was
taught by his mother he set off
she's the one who teach me how to cook
she's the one who teach me how to speak
english like if she was planning my
future somehow
al-arnab's food is a celebration of the
syrian home kitchen delicate flavors
that traveled with him on a grueling
trek across a continent i had to travel
10 different countries 10 10 different
countries for almost three months
starting from damascus to
lebanon
turkey macedonia
hungary austria germany france and
and then finally the uk
but it was a moment with an aid worker
as the boat he was on arrived on the
shores of greece battle arnhem says he
knew leaving syria was the right
decision
we were on that boat it's supposed to be
for nine people and we were 56 on it
i remember that lady waving to us and i
do remember that look on her face
like if she was more happy than me that
i'm safe you know
safe yes but his onward journey would
take months
before crossing into britain he became
stuck like so many other refugees in the
french port of calais how long were you
stuck there for 64 days 64 days sleeping
on a church that yeah
that must have been very hard
it's
it was very hard yes al-arnab says it
was almost always small acts of kindness
that kept him going lots of people who
weren't happy to see syrian refugees
traveling through europe
i would say yes many many
um
i don't know if i'm i'm super lucky
so i always been surrounded by angels
but
if you lick if you look in your in your
heart and you can find
kindness and happiness you can see in
other people's face as well
after surviving a harrowing journey to
britain on the back of a truck
al-arnab longed to feed people as he had
in damascus and started hosting pop-ups
to raise money for charity when a friend
convinced him to start a gofundme page
to open his own restaurant you raised 50
000 pounds
and now you have a restaurant now i have
a restaurant
his award-winning imad syrian kitchen is
celebrated for its baba ghanoush a
roasted eggplant dish with tahini garlic
olive oil and lemon unless if you want
to play a dive right yeah please go for
it
this is smokiness
right away
and there's a sweetness to it as well
yeah
the sweetness comes from the pomegranate
molasses
marinated grilled chicken with spiced
fried potato
try to keep it all for myself and his
personal favorite the kebab al hindi you
need to try the kebab with the tomato
soup with the tomato sauce okay i would
say
you need to try this chili sauce and you
call it
yes and shata just means does mean right
and
what we have from our chili sauce is
combination between tomatoes please be
careful it's really hot it's really hot
i can do it okay oh it is hot yeah i
told you so okay al-arnab's wife and
daughters are also now safely with him
in london but his incredible journey
from syria to britain is never far from
his mind to date al-arnab has raised
close to three hundred thousand dollars
for the choose love charity which helps
refugees around the world
in every single stage of my journey it
was people support
every single stage
and this is what i love about
about london you can find
kindness in in every corner in london
your food is a love letter to damascus
but it also sounds like it's also a love
letter to london as well i would say
it's love letter from damascus to london
yeah
for cbs saturday morning empty hazard
london
i love his story
so much of
his life could have gone another
direction there are refugees all over
the world who haven't found a place to
live
so his story is just all the more joyous
and the way he's been embraced i mean i
think that's the key with refugees all
over whether whether you're a refugee
who's cooking for someone creating
something whatever it is being embraced
in the city where you go and where you
are and people embracing your culture as
part of theirs is well i said it's all
about just small acts of kindness yes
and just so that just add up and lead to
what he's been able to accomplish
including this puppy here
the polo yes it's infused vodka
mint infused i should say
a little honey agave if you are vegan
and oh yeah mix it up you put a little
lemon in there and voila yes
delicious
refreshing
yummy